we're learning new information in the
case of a missing Connecticut mom from
the latest arrest warrant Michelle
trakone Eze was charged with evidence
tampering for a second time yesterday
her boyfriend Fotis Doulos was charged
again for that same crime just a day
earlier both are implicated in the
disappearance of Jennifer doulos CBS
this morning Saturday co-host Michelle
Miller is here Michelle what are the
authorities saying today they're saying
a lot police accused Fotis Toulouse of
committing a quote crime against
Jennifer and say he and his girlfriend
then disposed of the evidence and
invented alibis the new details come
more than three months since Jennifer
Doulos vanished
Michelle trikona said nothing Thursday
as she left the Connecticut State Police
barracks on bond she had turned herself
in on charges in connection with the
disappearance of Connecticut mom
Jennifer doulos Andrew Bowman is her
attorney
remember that Michelle is presumed
innocent and she should one day earlier
Fotis doulos was also arrested for a
second time and charged with evidence
tampering later released on $500,000
bond it's an exhausting fight I love my
children both Doulos and trakone 'as
previously pleaded not guilty on charges
of tampering with evidence and hindering
the prosecution neither have been
charged with murder but investigators
believe the vanished mother of five was
murdered on May 24th in a new 38 page
arrest warrant police say they found
Jennifer's DNA on the seats of a work
truck doulos had been driving according
to the warrant police asked Rick onus
why doulos would wash the truck after
Jennifer disappeared she told them well
obviously all the evidence says because
you showed me the picture of the blood
in the door it's because the body of
Jennifer at some point was in there CBS
News analyst Rikki Kleeman both of them
should be worried because at some point
there is always that possibility that
the police could decide that they want
to go all the way even without a body
and bring a murder charge in June we sat
down with dual OSes attorney norm
pattice who told us the case
against his client was built on
speculation and hysteria Jennifer is an
extremely sympathetic person right now
the nation is rallied behind her because
she's a missing mom of five beautiful
children that doesn't mean my clients
the villain do Louis's attorney told CBS
news in a statement he wishes the State
Police spent more time looking for
Jennifer and less trying to build a case
against his client Doulos is expected to
be back in court next week and his
attorney says he will plead not guilty
to that new charge yeah you really feel
for those children involved five of them
Thank You Michelle